previously on TV sins we all can change
if I can change and you can change my
[Applause]
name is Barry Allen immediate an
aggressively confident narration to the
outside world I'm an ordinary forensic
scientist how about a twenty
four-year-old scientist heading up a
forensic department in a large city be
considered ordinary even without the
flash abilities this kids pretty
extraordinary on the flash show spends
the first 33 seconds on expedited
exposition then shifts directly to an
additional 33 seconds of cliche written
previous episode crap to understand what
I'm about to tell you you need to do
something first
hey we sort of just met and you're
heaping on some heavy obligation tactics
how about I don't do for you we built
trust for a while and then see if this
red flag stops flapping in my face you
need to believe can you do that good I
get this feeling iris doesn't really
want me to respond to her question
because she didn't even pause for an
answer
she's narration bulldozing bull racing
narrow zhing xing xiang either way take
a breath iris vloggers um that's not
cool on any level I'm not even sure how
you carry someone going that speed and
not say set them on fire or something
along those lines but pretty sure you
should get permission first
also DC superhero has a conversation
with an or me on a rooftop cliche
literally just hit Send you can do your
voice it's crazy that iris doesn't know
this is Barry she's grown up with this
mother I don't care about the masks and
the ghosts facing of his voice she
should know that's Barry also speaking
of Barry the crazy way iris is cheesing
whenever flash is around indicates she
really only needs to be in his presence
to get there I guess it's the spare
electricity emanating from his suit why
should I call you
three fine suggestions suggestions is a
terrible superhero named iris also Barry
would get up to speed quickly at TV sins
action scenes with cars can feel like
paint-by-numbers when the camera keeps
panning to the grill like they're
showing something interesting is there a
reason to zoom in when there's no
product placement or anything kind of a
tool steals a yellow Humvee kind of tool
buys a yellow home that's colorist why
swerve to avoid a man when the metalhead
was perfectly fine with cruising through
bodies a moment ago even if he instantly
realized lash was a metahuman why not
attempt to plow him over just in case
that works 13 fractures that's a new
record are we handing out awards for
fractures because this seems like a
really enthusiastic report about broken
bones you also have a concussion three
cracked ribs and a bruised spleen so we
went ahead and twisted your body into
comfortable lounge pants and a shirt so
that you could feel relaxed because why
use a hospital gown to cover your
important bits when you have friends
that will ignore your cries for mercy
what exactly did you hit and why does
this guy look so happy to ask this
question
he has perla smirk and if there's one
thing I can't stand its narration nope
perma smirk update my most hated sins
you're lucky to knock out your teeth
those puppies don't grow back is this
foreshadowing is there a toothless flash
in the future more importantly even if
his teeth were knocked out veneers or a
thing strange thing is I feel like I
knew him what do you mean he means he
feels like he knew the guy frost what a
dumb question to write into a script but
a question would be how so or in what
wait so how do I fight a guy that's made
of steel so he Martha
I just taking point while I went down
the lead I need you to work with him
until I get back in other words make up
some sciency stuff to throw him off and
maybe talk louder about your plan while
in a crowded office
[Music]
by the cash flashback flash flashback I
give up
I don't know how do you remember all
this stuff Barry because he's a little
freak just like his old man don't talk
about my dad or what is he gonna murder
me too man this is a super dark episode
of the Goldbergs also I continue to
reiterate this is not how bullies work
school age bullies don't give a [ __ ]
about family dynamics they make funny or
clothes or your face or your nipple
sighs please go for the easy pickings
man Allen hey Allen Hey
okay Barry blanks out during a flashback
while in a room full of people and only
one person notices and then when he
comes to they walk out of a now empty
room which means everyone left while
Barry stood there like a statue oh well
bunch of [ __ ]
I find it doesn't matter how crazy it
was like they sparked off of him so
you're wondering what prompted you to
use a ridiculous amount of deadly force
against a non-violent offender rather
than shooting at the vehicles tires no
what is going on with you two
I think it's fine after watching Barry
back away like this Eddie shut up his
concern ohmmeter
from they bake cookies together on the
weekend too they bake cookies together
on the weekend and then I need your help
solving an old case of mine what case is
that
murder Barry's mother good guy asks bad
guy to help solve the murder they commit
a cliche and yes I'm assuming but all
the tell-tale TV signs are here from the
permis Merck to the dred field music
sure I mean I've seen how close you two
are sure why not have another awkward
chat about the love triangle but this
time at the scene of a crime no real
reason to focus on gathering evidence
when there's a woman to conquer
[Music]
more flashbacks what is this Brooklyn
nine-nine How I Met Your Mother
hey sure let the man run right beside
you don't attempt to tackle or trip him
because that won't build meaningless
tension while Barry technically works
for the police force he's not actually a
police officer
and should definitely not be involved in
the physical chase and apprehension of a
suspect also Barry decides to run
straight down this alley and rap around
to cut off the perp which is incredibly
reckless considering one these men would
have a clear shot of seeing Barry
dashing and B Barry has to address
Eddy's confusion with a shortcut which
makes no sense but we're all going to
just pretend it doesn't say I move on
because logic did I get that convenience
television conveniently shows the news
which conveniently reveals the wanted
information of a dangerous man that is
conveniently present in this exact
moment cliche
he crushes Iris's phone leaves a cash
tip and walks out forget the cafe filled
with people who also have cell phones
also what was this interaction
Tony seriously tracking down that one
girl from grade school just to creepily
hit on her and tell her not to write
about Flash help Barry didn't even
recognize Tony so it stands to reason
iris wouldn't either this whole thing
just seems super manufactured to create
an eventual damsel in distress situation
about this I no TV show has two TV show
but iris has taken a hell of a chance
here that the flash won't see this
wasn't going to her dad or Eddie make
more sense in the situation okay cops
daughter I can handle myself
iris seems perfectly happy in a
relationship with Eddie based on her
little office visit earlier so why is
she walking toward flash like he's a
cold drink of water for all she knows
he's an alien with three penises no wait
actually maybe moving the shells would
be the better idea
moving him might be a terrible idea if
he's broken her fracture anything hey
you're speeding haha see that's funny
because Eddie doesn't know about the
flash and Barry and you want a plan
how's this used to write about the
street right now you're gonna write
about me but what is the motivation here
their blog is barely noticeable by the
end of the episode it's a big deal when
it crosses a thousand views I can get a
thousand likes on Twitter for a Corgi
named cheddar that is even my dog who
cares about a blog written by her
elementary crush yes let me move you
down the hallway so you can see us
fighting rather than immediately take
you to a safe location like the police
station
[Music]
can we get some clarity on whether or
not the flash punched the metahuman
abilities out of this guy because it
seems like that supersonic punch did a
little more than temporarily knock him
over and I'm not sure we should be
celebrating just yet
use your gift to hurt people
not anymore nice talk coming from one of
the people choosing to imprison the
metahumans for life I'm not sure what
other options there are but maybe take
at least a second to think about it I've
gotten scattered post about this guy
that's on fire except that he doesn't
burn up firestorm shadowing he comes and
goes in the blink of an eye in a flash
roll commercials
hey don't you mean oink little piggy
shouldn't you run off the market what
should I call you
anything but the street and like that
he's gone I wanna fight you flash I
wouldn't want to fight me neither
besides I was off duties hmm wipe that
smirk off your face
focus I walk on the road oh right side
say walk left side safe walk middle
soonerlater hit the squeeze just like
grip
[Music]